Hi there everyone I'm Carmella and academic and research.
And I'm here today with Nina shack, a political advisor,
broadcaster and author of the new book, deep fakes,
and in Fokker lips, I think that's how you describe it.
I'm an expiration of fake news.
AI generated deep fakes and the dangerous political consequences of our
discipline is information, age welcoming. So, um,
let's, let's begin, um,
with kind of staring down the kind of technological black hole that you begin
the book with this, this staring into the world of deep fakes. Um,
what does it look like?
So I came across the deep, fake only about three years ago when they first,
less than three years ago when they first erupted on the internet.
And for those who don't know, and many listeners will know what a deep fake is.
Essentially an AI generated either partially or wholly fake piece of
media content. It could be a video, it can be an image, it can also be texts.
And I came to it as somebody who was advising the
former NATO secretary general,
and we were working on election interference and disinformation,
and what Russia was doing to really disrupt the politics of the Western world.
So when I first found a deep fake on this very obscure area of
the internet on Reddit and its first use was in non-consensual
pornography, I was like, Oh my goodness, this is huge.
Forget about fake news, forget about the disinformation,
all the kinds of manipulated media we've seen before.
This is the heralding of what's to come when you can actually fake
video and make it look like it's the real deal.
So immediately when it kind of came across it in pornography, I was like,
this is going to have massive implications on everything from politics
to also individuals. Um, and I kind of lay that out in the book,
but there is the first kind of introduction as to like what a deep fake actually
is.
And so most people thinking about this information probably in their minds,
I will recall maybe some dodgy tweets or Facebook posts, but,
but you're, you're, you're kind of sounding the alarm,
not about textual information,
but about the world of video and pictures and the things that we actually see
that seems so visceral to us.
Absolutely. So I think when I first came to deep fakes,
I recognized how potent they were because in our
current information ecosystem, right, which is like changing so quickly,
video has become the medium of communication.
And if you look at how it's changed over the last 30 years,
we first had the internet, then we had smartphones.
Then we have social media and I come from a part of the world, Nepal, you know,
part of the developing world where, um,
until recently people were just kind of completely disconnected from this
information ecosystem.
But now everybody has a smartphone and everybody consumes
information. Mostly through video. If you look at the stats for next year,
I think it's over 82% of global internet traffic is going to be to the
consumption of video content. So just at this time,
then video is becoming the most important medium of human
communication,
which is going to reach parts of the globe in a way that no other form
of human communication has ever done before.
That is just the time when it can be subverted by AI. I should point out that,
um, when I talk about deep fakes,
it's essentially what I describe as a malicious use of synthetic media,
synthetic media, being AI generated content.
And there'll be loads of positive use cases. I mean,
it's completely going to open up like the creative industries and advertising
industries, but there will be bad use cases. If I, if I told you, Hey,
if you're a criminal or you want to do some kind of political disinformation and
you have the power to make any video or audio,
any media of anyone saying or doing anything, you can see how that can,
that technology can quickly be used by the bad guys.
And I think what I wanted to do with this book,
so the hook was the deep fake because I thought, wow,
that's so fascinating when I first came across them.
But increasingly as I started writing the book, I was like, well,
there's something else going on here.
And that is that our information ecosystem in the age of information has just
become so dangerous and untrustworthy.
And I think a part of that is because it has changed so exponentially with
these advances that I've just described from internet to social media,
to smartphones, to the coming age of AI,
that society simply hasn't had time to adjust.
And if you look at kind of the big changes in the ways that humans have
communicated from the printing press to photography, I mean,
there were 400 years between that, right?
From the invention of Gutenberg printing press to the advent of modern
photography. And I just don't think we're ready for what AI can do.
I'm not saying technology is bad. I'm just saying it will have bad use cases.
And my first thing that I wanted to do with writing this book is to talk about
that. So people recognize it's not only coming,
it's already here and we need to be able to recognize it.
And, and boiling down deep fakes, just so that people know. So, so in, in,
in very, very concrete times, what do they let people do cry? Any video,
looking like anyone that people want, um,
which is entirely synthetic.
So a deep fake is essentially a maliciously used piece of
synthetic media.
So synthetic media is either wholly generated by AI or partially
generated by AI. And we're still at the very,
very beginning of the synthetic media revolution.
So what we've seen so far with deep fakes and a lot of people who talk about
defects are like, Oh my God, this is the end of democracy. It can make you say,
or do make you take anyone or say, or do anything.
But the reality is the barriers to entry right now are
still quite high. However, they're coming down very, very quickly.
So essentially what that means is that wholly would level special effects.
You know, the type of things that you see in these blockbusters,
which would previously have been inaccessible to anyone,
except those with a lot of money, you know, a whole,
a special effects studio that is basically going to become something that
anybody can create or do.
And the reason why they are dangerous or can be used
dangerously is because of the AI element of it. Um,
and this is where I kind of like go into the anecdotes in my story where,
um, you can take content of anyone,
so I can take your personal information and then create a deep fake of you
either in a video form or I can steal your voice and I can make you say
something with audio. And like I mentioned,
this only started really coming about three years ago.
And it's already getting to the point where it's quite advanced and in the next
kind of 18 to 12 months, it's good.
The barriers to entry are going to come down even further.
So it's next level disinformation,
but this is not only the domain of high geopolitics or, um,
you know, the information war between China and Russia and the United States.
This is something that's going to impact people in their very personal lives.
It's something, uh, it's,
it's a technology that already is and will continue to be misused by criminals.
It's a technology that can be used by somebody who has a grudge
against you, for example, by making, um,
as we've already been seeing revenge porn. Um,
so this is something that really has the possibility to impact
everyone, not only on the level of the political,
but even in our most personal lives.
And is this kind of all of that together? Is that the [inaudible]?
Did I pronounce that correctly?
Yeah, the apocalypse, it's just that a nice,
a word that I decided to kind of throw into the title. It was actually,
it was actually a word that was coined by a U S technologist in
2016 when he was kind of a warning of the era of fake
news. Um, and essentially how I described the apocalypse is,
um, our increasingly dangerous information ecosystem that's untrustworthy.
And it's something that I think is going to continue to become more dangerous
and more untrustworthy. So the InFocus lips I think, is going to advance.
And within that, I think, um,
AI and deep stakes are going to definitely play a role.
So I think the main point,
and this is what researchers like you also are thinking about Carl is how
do we, um,
change the infrastructure of our information ecosystem as to make it more
trustworthy and safe, because it is so important, evermore.
Important? Well, there's lots of,
kind of stops that we might take on our tour through the [inaudible].
So in the next 40 minutes or so, um, but let's begin with,
I think perhaps the most obvious,
the one foregrounded very recently in a big report in parliament that we've been
talking about this for years, Russia, um,
zoom us into one of these operations that the Russia is mounted.
What does that actually look like when you begin to kind of tear it apart and
kind of look at the innards?
So, I mean, I,
my background is somebody who was started working in
like national security and European politics in, at the start of,
for about 10 years.
And I was really at the front lines of watching what was happening
when Russia annexed, Crimea,
and also then invaded Eastern Ukraine Ukraine in 20 2013.
And the really interesting thing about Russia is that I have a whole chapter in
my book on Russia because I call Russia the monster. I say,
they are the masters of information warfare,
and it's not just something that they started doing and then vocalists, right?
They were doing this in the cold war.
And I recount a story in my book about how successful they were at spreading
disinformation and consistently throughout history,
they have used disinformation and information operations to have an outsized
geopolitical influence. So if you look back at the cold war,
one of the most daring disinformation campaigns,
the Soviets ever launched was called operation infection.
Now this was the myth that
HIV AIDS was a virus created by the CIA in a
laboratory to kill African-Americans.
And in the eighties, this took this,
th this seed of disinformation that the Soviets came up with was kind of planted
in a newspaper in India. And then over the years,
it was like reiterated in the Soviet press and it kind of grew and grew and grew
and grew until about almost a decade later, it went completely viral.
Now in the info clips with modern technology,
Russia still has more or less the same strategy.
It's just that the tools by which to spread this kind of disinformation have
become far more potent. So if we fast forward,
I kind of do a little tour of what the Russians did in 2016,
because I was working on these political events. Then, um,
if you look at what happened in the election,
one of the things they did apart from hacking,
and also trying to compromise the critical voting infrastructure,
one of the things that they did,
which was super interesting was social media operations.
And this is something that they have become really good at, um,
in the Ukrainian war. So they really cut their teeth, uh, in about 2013,
2014. And then they started looking at the S not only in 2016,
but for a period of three years,
they started kind of looking at the U S in 2013.
And what they did was really find a way where they could
attack Western democracy from within and the tactic to do this was to
cause division within society.
And what they did was create these communities on social media,
by using Instagram, Facebook, um, Twitter,
where they built up people's tribal identities on
both sides of the political spectrum.
So it's wrong to think that Russian disinformation just targets one side,
either the left or the right of the political spectrum.
And they injected these groups with a lot of pride. So for instance,
it could be Confederates, you know, Texas secessionists, uh,
gun owners on the right, on the conservative side of the spectrum.
And on the other side of the spectrum, it was, um, African-American groups,
you know, feminists. And then after they had kind of built up these groups,
loads of feelings of pride, uh, a distinct identity,
they started injecting them with messages of legitimate political grievances.
And it was so Doster. Thirdly,
one of the things that I document in the book is how time and time again,
Russian disinformation starting with operation infection has, um,
focused on the African-American community. And they did that in 2016 as well,
where they use Facebook to build up all these black lives matter groups around
the, some of the controversial shootings and police brutality.
But at the same time, they were also creating these blue lives matter groups,
where they were talking about, you know, uh,
we need to protect our police and we can't defund the police.
And it was so ironic because as I was writing the book, I mean,
I wrote it in a few weeks, uh, during lockdown that's when, just at the end,
when we're going to press,
I had warned how this would continue to be an issue that the Russians would
agitate on. Um, that's when the George George Floyd killing happened.
And that's not to say that everything that's happened since in America is
because of the Russians,
because there is a long history of complicated race relations,
but it is prime picking ground.
And it is such an opportunity for them to cause these divisions in society.
And the interesting thing that they're doing in 2020.
So the methods keep evolving and they keep on becoming more sophisticated.
And in 2020,
what we have discovered the Russians are doing vis-a-vis the election in the
United States is now they've kind of outsourced their
troll farms, which they hadn't St.
Petersburg in 2016 to Africa where a
Ghana, they had, uh, an NGO, which set out,
which was set up to extensively, be a legitimate human rights,
NGO on the people that were working there were actually running the social media
influence operations to divide the United States ahead of the election.
So the point is information warfare is an old game,
but it's becoming more and more potent. And with these new tools,
it's becoming more and more dangerous. We see it in our polarized politics.
It's not only because of the Russians, it's not only because of the Chinese,
but it's something where we as democracy, democracies are very vulnerable.
And the other important point is that Russia has been so successful in these
information.
Operations is that other countries are now looking to Russia and
seeking to emulate what they're doing.
So one very interesting thing that I go into into the book and maybe we'll come
into that is how China has increasingly been playing these games,
especially in light of COVID given the geopolitical consequences for
China. Um, vis-a-vis, COVID.
I mean, that particular case kind of exposes a tactic.
I've always been fascinated by and always worry that most people really kind of
don't quite grasp, which is the way that a state can squat on kind of one side.
And then the other side of a political spectrum.
I think we often kind of think that disinformation operations are all about,
you know, making Brexit happen or making Trump win, you know,
trying to force a particular outcome,
but not actually that they're on both sides,
arguing for both things at the same time, um, trying to make everyone angry.
And that is so key because,
and I think you're so right to point that out because over the past few weeks,
when the Russia issue has come to the fore and the news agenda here in the UK,
again, I've had so many people come to me and say, well,
it can't possibly be because in 2016, they were supposedly in favor of Brexit.
And now, you know, Oh, they were supposedly in favor of Jeremy Corbyn,
but that is exactly the strategy you cause a
division and chaos. And you hit a democracy where it hurts,
you know, because of our freedom of speech and our freedom of expression,
you seek to drive the rifts into democracy on all sides of the spectrum.
They did it here in the UK with regards to both the conservatives and
labor. And you're absolutely right in the United States in 2016,
they did it, um, for both Donald Trump as well as Bernie Sanders.
So it works on both sides.
The last question I have for you, Nina is a difficult one.
It's an important one, but difficult one. I get asked it all the time. Um,
and it's, it's that big question which has proven very,
very difficult to kind of get around and to therefore kind of get real serious
resources and political will mobilized against this problem.
And the question is, does any of this actually matter,
how do we measure the impact of this? You know,
socially it isn't this just social media advertising.
And does that actually work at all? You know, um,
does any of this really shift anyone's minds or beliefs in any way?
Um.
Yeah, so I think that's a really good question and my answer would be,
it absolutely matters because that if we're looking at it from
the dimension of foreign interference, right? So if you say to me, Oh, well,
it's, it's, it's lazy to say that Trump won because of the Russians.
I would agree with you, I'd say absolutely. You know,
that is a lazy explanation for a very complicated set of reasons as to why
Trump won the election. And it isn't only because the Russians intervened.
However, the fact that the Russians did intervene is a fact.
So that is something we cannot deny. And we shouldn't deny. Um,
moreover it's not just about foreign interference, right?
It's not just about what the Russians are doing, what the Chinese are doing,
what the Saudis are doing, they're doing it. Okay. That's one angle.
The second angle is that this corroded and corrupted information ecosystem is
increasingly coming to define our own domestic politics as well.
So if you look at it from the political angle, I mean,
really what's at stake here is liberal democracy, right?
Do you want to have a liberal democracy in a kind of functioning
society? Because if you do, you need to have some kind of basis,
some kind of shared reality,
some kind of objective platform on which to decide these are the facts,
and this is how we're going to run society.
So it doesn't work if it's being disrupted by foreign powers from the
outside and internally from, uh, by domestic agents as well.
So if you end up in this state where you're just constantly having information
warfare, because that is literally what it is,
then our society is going to suffer.
So let's say you're not interested in any of that.
And you don't care about what the Russians are doing,
what the Chinese are doing,
and you don't care about like domestic politics either. I would say again,
it matters because it impacts all of us in other ways.
First of all, businesses, every business is at risk and the InFocus lips,
every business faces reputational risk, every business, um,
can be subjected to disinformation. I mean, we're already seeing it, uh, how,
you know, on social media,
these campaigns have been run saying this and this business supported Trump.
So boy caught them or say, you know, there was another instance where, uh,
there was a lot of fake news about Starbucks, um,
giving free coffees to people of, uh, people of color.
Every business is at risk of disinformation in this corrupt and dangerous
information ecosystem aside from business.
Then there's also you the personal, when it comes to the very individual level.
And because of the way that, um,
defects in AI will make this information,
basically a tool that's available to anyone you yourself are
at the front lines of potentially being, um,
becoming a target of different disinformation in a really, really personal way,
because what deep fakes will allow you to do,
or will it allow a bad actor to do is to actually steal your
voice or to steal your face and to make you say, or do something you didn't say.
And again, the first instance, it's not, it's not make-believe right.
It's already happening. It's happening in pornography.
It's happening mostly against women right now,
but that is a harbinger of what's to come,
because let's say, I just don't like you, Carl,
and I want to ruin your reputation.
I could make a leaked audio tape of you saying something very disagreeable,
which would be enough to get you canceled in these political climates.
And I could just put that on Google with your name on it.
And that would be the first thing that comes up. And you could try,
you could try to explain that to potential employer and say, Oh, you know,
that wasn't me, that's a deep fake, but they might just say that, you know what,
it's just too complicated. And so it matters for a politics,
both domestically and geopolitically.
It matters for every single business and it matters in your personal life.
And this is why I think it's not just a question of defects. It's,
it's much bigger than that.
It's about how is our information ecosystem becomes so dangerous?
How are we facing this monumental crisis of,
and disinformation where we've all become potential targets and what the hell do
we do about it? So it absolutely matters.
All right. Well,
thank you for that extremely powerful response to that difficult question. It's,
let's pull away from the Russia station on our grant or, um, and,
and go to somewhere. You've already mentioned domestic politics. Um,
so in exactly what way do you think have
domestic politicians or campaigns kind of looked at the Russia example? I mean,
kind of drawn lessons from that about the way that they were going to wage
politics and the digital age?
Well,
I think the interesting thing about politics in the digital
age is, is the imperative just to win, you know,
is any, is anything, uh,
allowed when it comes to comes when it comes to winning.
So can you say and do anything or is the imperative,
especially in Western democracies to, to win,
but also to have some kind of cohesive society.
And I think that's kind of the crossroads where we stand at right
now and in my book, um,
when I look at the Western democracies and the domestic threat and the domestic
challenge,
I use the United States as a case study because obviously we have the U S
election coming up and I look at particularly one actor,
who's got so much influence. And of course that's Donald Trump.
And I know so much has been written about Donald Trump,
but so much has been said about Donald Trump.
But I think it's worth retreading that ground because he is
the leader of the free world and where America leads, you know,
the rest of the Western world will follow and seeing how fast and
he has been with not only lying,
but also disinformation on the use of manipulated media,
including the use of deep fakes has been really alarming because to a
certain extent,
it doesn't matter whether or not Trump wins the election in 2020,
uh, that precedent has already been set.
So I'm really interested to see if Trump loses, you know,
what happens then what happens to then fall clips?
What happens to the information ecosystem,
because it's not just the Republicans who are using this tactics,
the Democrats are too. And I, and I talk about that in my book. Um,
this is the perennial kind of debate. You know, what,
where the Democrats have been like, Oh, well,
if the Republicans use these kind of disinformation tactics,
then should we do it too? Or does that make us just as bad?
And the reality is they have used these kinds of tactics.
There was a famous instance where there was a seat in
Alabama and the Democrats run,
Rhonda disinformation companies fired by the Russians against the very safe
Republican candidates who were supposed to win that seat. Um,
so I just think the main question is what
happens with our domestic information ecosystem and is it
just going to become one where anything goes in order to win?
And we see those kinds of divides here in the UK as well, right?
Where everything has become so polarized,
where you have to choose a side and any kind of nuance
or any kind of position being a centrist is way
out dated. So I think this is.
Right 1996, isn't it?
This is one of the biggest challenges facing Western democracies in my view, uh,
it's true that we are facing a lot of, uh,
geopolitically we're facing a lot of hostile forces in the world is changing.
However,
I don't think we've quite as a democracy has figured out
how we're going to run our politics in the information age,
because we do have certain rights, freedom of expression,
freedom of information, which are inalienable and should be protected. However,
we haven't quite figured out how to square that with the dangerous information
ecosystem.
Yeah. I mean, it, it, it's, it's the way as you described, you know, the,
these techniques have been imported into domestic politics that makes me so
nervous that whilst it kind of remained in the hands of Russia, you know,
at least the techniques were kind of shadowy and kind of felt legitimate.
You know, the intelligence agencies might be trying to interfere,
but at least we could kind of know that was wrong and try and stop here.
But it kind of now, it just,
it begins to feel like actually they're just like baked in campaigning tactics.
They've become com ethically normalized where people can't even really see a
moral problem in using them. And, and I, I mean,
it really, uh,
makes me recall the last Indian election where I believe every single mainstream
party in India was each court by Facebook and the other tech giants in an
elicit influence campaign.
All of them kind of implied that it was just now a campaigning tactic that it's
kind of embarrassing if you don't do it.
Yeah. And that all evidence you're absolutely right.
All evidence seems to suggest that that is the new normal. I mean,
these researchers at the university of Oxford, who've been kind of tracking,
they call it computational propaganda and influence operations on social media
found that, you know, the number of countries doing it had gone up to 70,
I think it was last year from 17, a few years ago.
And that included many Western countries.
So I think the genie is already out of the bottle. Right.
I don't think we're putting it back in.
So I think the question then is how do we,
as citizens feel about that,
especially in Western democracies and how do we think that is going to
impact our politics? Because it definitely will impact our politics,
especially in these countries where the
state does not have a monopoly over the information ecosystem, like for example,
in China. Um,
so it really can be a case of too much information having the effect of
censorship, which is not exactly how you would think of it when you,
when you think an abundance of information would be a good thing rather than a
bad thing. But if it's an abundance of bad information,
what are we going to do about it?
And these are really the big questions that we need to think about it.
And I honestly think these are the biggest and most important
challenges for, for our democracies in the 21st century.
And in the next five to 10 years.
We all, we all gonna get solutions. I promise everyone,
I'm not going to leave us in this, in this Morris of despair.
But I think there is, there is one further stop we need to go to in, in,
in terms of diagnosing the problem. And,
and it's not stopped that we tend to kind of talk less about kind of inference
operations happening elsewhere. I mean, here in the West, of course,
we're obsessed by us politics. So we talk about that all the time.
We're obsessed by Brexit and British politics. We talk about that all the time,
and we'll just kind of information warfare look outside of the West.
What is it like in Saudi Arabia or Nepal or, um, or India, in fact,
you know, places that would just, we just have less, uh, you know,
we just talk about less than a daily basis.
Uh,
so this was one of the most interesting chapters in the book for me to research
and write,
because obviously I came at it from the angle of like Western democracies and
foreign countries trying to undermine Western democracy.
A democracy is through information warfare,
but what was also really interesting to look at was, you know,
the rest of the world. Um,
and of course the dangerous information ecosystem
impacts the rest of the world as well,
which is one of the reasons why I think what happens in the West is so important
because if we, as kind of bastion of the free world,
can't deal with this bad information ecosystem with all the institutions and
all the protections that we have in place. And we do,
then there is no hope for those countries,
which have less rigid safeguards. Um,
and I kind of go into a little bit about, um,
I grew up in South Asia. Um,
I grew up in Nepal in India and I go into how then lips has been super
dangerous in parts of the world like India,
where misinformation and disinformation has been rife
on these new kind of,
as this people have plugged into this new information ecosystem with, uh,
tools like the internet and smartphones for the first time,
how they've been less able to deal with some of the disinformation that's gone
viral.
And I give some instances about how in India there's been like numerous cases of
people being killed because of virus viral misinformation spreading on
WhatsApp, for example, uh,
there was also the case of Burma where there was literally, um,
an ethnic genocide against the Rohingya,
which was very much fond on by online disinformation,
which was spread in the case of Burma, uh, actually hate speech, um,
very much on Facebook, right? So online. Um, it's,
it's fascinating to me when I go back to Nepal and I see people who
in the village, you know, barely 10 years ago had running well,
they still don't have running water or electricity,
but they will have a mobile phone and be able to get on the internet.
So a lot of the people in the developing world for lack of a better word,
who are first coming into this information ecosystem have less
protection than we do in the West, because at least in the West,
we have some form of inoculation and we understand that this is underway.
And we also have learned because we've seen some of the more crude and
rudimentary forms of disinformation and misinformation,
and we can recognize them, right. We've been inoculated against the worst,
some of the dangerous and part in part,
I'm writing this book because I want to help inoculate against the coming danger
of deep fake, but in parts of the developing world that doesn't exist yet.
So not only can these tools
cause be used as a,
as a form of kind of oppressing human rights and for real violence. And I mean,
we've literally seen it in the case of ethnic genocide. It's it's, uh,
it's, it's, uh, it's a place in many places in many,
in many parts of the world.
I fear that the citizenry simply not ready for the infant
clips where it could do a lot more damage. So again,
I think we have a responsibility to build a more,
a safer information environment for all these people who are going to be let out
into the wild West and potentially be, be harmed by what's out there.
I suppose,
that they are two very stark reminders of what the consequences possibly can be.
You know, sometimes literally death and destruction and genocide, um,
as very tangible reminders to anyone with lingering doubts as to the
significance of this problem. Um, yeah. Um.
I wanted to quickly also mention is
there there something called the Liar's dividend? So, um, with deep fakes,
and this is one really interesting thing that's happening with defects.
So just the fact that you have this technology out there where,
you know, you can fake video evidence, um,
means that for in certain parts of the world where there's already kind of a
fragile consensus around human rights,
abuses and video is seen as a form of documenting that the mere existence
of deep fakes hurts them in the other way,
by meaning that everybody gets posable deniability.
So let's say you have a video evidence of someone committing an atrocity,
um, because defects exist. Now, you can say, well,
that's just a deep fake, even when it isn't.
And I kind of talk about in the book, how that happened, for example, in, in,
in Gabon, where there was a failed coup to top because, uh,
the prime minister kind of went missing for, for a few months.
And it was because he had had a stroke, but when he appeared on TV,
he looked kind of strange because he had had the stroke and he had like Botox to
make his face look a bit more straight.
And what his opponent said was that that was a deep fake video.
And that wasn't actually the president and the president had died and they use
that as an opportunity to have a to top. So even if there isn't a deep fake,
the fact that you, there is no more consensus around visual media,
serving as legitimate evidence can have an impact in the other way as
well.
Okay.
So there's one more stop we need to get to before we get to the solutions.
So I think,
I think we've began to diagnose a problem and get our hand around how this
happens, where it happens, why, um,
I want to talk blame MENA, who is, who is to blame for this? You, you,
you you've, you've mentioned quite a few times, um,
this kind of corrupted or broken information ecosystem, um,
who is responsible for building that and,
and what have they done to make it so vulnerable to the kinds of campaigns we've
been, we've been talking about today.
Yeah. You know what I wish I could tell you,
this is the person who is to blame, but I think,
I think a lot of this has come about by, you know,
the tech utopias.
So the tech utopia that the age of information was supposed to bring,
we've already seen. Um, there are many, many downsides as well.
I mean, technology itself is net neutral, right? It's,
it's just a driver of human intention and human intention is neither wholly
good nor wholly bad.
So the kind of tech revolution or the age of information of the last three
decades is now manifesting itself in both its
amazing aspect as well. It's very, very, very dark aspect.
So I don't think that there is one person to blame. However,
what I will say is that we should not be so naive as
to think that the new developments that are coming down the line.
So for example, when it comes to the advances in AI,
which is what I'm talking about here in particular with,
with regards to deep fake, that that is not going to be used by bad guys.
You know, it's going to have incredible applications. Of course it will,
but we should not be so naive as to think that there won't be opportunists who
will use it for bad. So whether that's a rogue state,
whether that's an opportunist domestic politician,
whether that is a criminal, whether that's a fraudster,
whether that's just your mate, who you really off,
who wants to get some form of revenge on you. Um,
I think this more than having one person to blame is the ultimate
and ultimately a reflection on human nature, right?
Because all this technology which is coming together with human nature is
showing both the best sides and the worst sides of humanity.
And I think that the only thing that we have to do right now is we need to get a
little bit of a handle on some of the bad sides.
And how we do that. This is the final stop here we are.
How do we help tell me this is fixable.
Tell me that the information age is not going to be one where inflammation is
more corrupt, dead and corruptive than ever before.
Tell me that there's a way through.
I think there is a way through,
but unfortunately there is no silver bullet answer
and because we are going to be entering now a period
of tremendous flux, both Jew politically,
um,
not to mention because of the huge kind of exponential advances in technology
and how that's going to impact our society.
I think there's going to be a lot more chaos before there is structure and calm
again. So I think the first instance in the first instance,
what we need to do is to name it and understand what's happening.
And that was my contribution in writing this book because I kind of saw all of
these trends and how they were coming together over my,
the last decade of my work, where I've started with what Russia was doing.
And then I saw how, you know,
kind of some of the Western influence operation campaigns were running and what
was happening with Brexit, what was happening around Trump?
What was an increasingly polarized debate in our own society.
And then I saw how women were being targeted by deep fake non-consensual
pornography. I think the first thing is to consent,
put a conceptual framework around that.
And that's what I've called in focal lips, right? This,
this information ecosystem, which is increasingly dangerous and untrustworthy,
um, we all are impacted by it. I mean, you,
you raised the point earlier in the interview and I think this is something that
many people ask me saying, well, you know, why does it matter? Is it,
it's just a bit nonsense because it's not tangible. So I think we need to,
first of all,
say stress how important it is and how it impacts all of us.
And then the second part. So that's the first thing understand.
The second part is, um,
we begin to defend more proactively and
there is no one organization or one body that can do that.
You know, it's not, the answers are not going to come from regulation alone.
They're not going to come from policymakers alone.
You can't just go to the big tech companies and be like you fix it because it is
ultimately not a tech problem. It's a societal problem.
It's a human nature problem.
And we all these contingent parts of society need to work together to come
up with solutions. So you need to take a network approach,
obviously that is pretty complicated,
but the good work has already started.
Then in the kind of last chapter of my book,
I lay out various people in organizations that are
tackling different parts of the problem.
So you have technologists who are trying to create AI, um,
machine learning systems that can identify deep fakes online.
And then you have people who are taking more of a human rights angle.
And then you have people who are, uh, you know,
looking at the policy and legal arenas. I think it's not, again,
it's not something that's gonna be fixed overnight.
It's not something that's going to be fixed by one body.
It's only something that when society recognizes
how much this impacts everything, that society as a whole has to mobilize and,
um,
well do something about our corrupt information ecosystem and the information
age.
And, and, and, and all we mobilizing. I mean, are you optimistic?
Like is what should be happening happening now?
I think it will probably get worse before it gets better. Um,
but I think that will be a tipping point
where Mo there are more and more resources
dedicated to this. I mean, if I was in charge of the government, for example,
I wouldn't have, you know,
technol tech as like a subsection of what government looks at. I mean,
it should be above everything, you know, it should I,
and unfortunately my kind of,
I can only speak from my experience of working in the
policy politics world,
where I have found too large of a gap between the understanding of
policymakers and politicians and the scale of the problem.
So I can only speak from that perspective where I have
seen a lot more work needs to be done,
but the good thing is that there are people who really, really get it.
People like you as well, Carl, we need more,
we need more Carl Millers in the world, um,
who are trying to bridge that gap. And I think there,
there will be a moment when we truly understand
that this is probably one of the biggest challenges of
the information age and I'm, you know, of course, of course it is.
We're living in the information age and there's,
there's the Bob and dangerous information ecosystem we need to fix it. And, um,
I'm hopeful that we will be mobilizing towards them.
Well, there we go.
Everyone we've reached the end of our tour through the in lips. Um,
thank you so much, Nina. I thank you to intelligence squad.
And of course thank you to all of you for listening or watching this.
If you do want to find out more about the fates and the info clips,
you can buy the link in the podcast description below. But, um, I,
I, at least we only to say to union, I thank you so much. One more time.
And I hope this is a word, even if I can't pronounce it,
always that we'll be talking about a lot more in the future. Thank you.